ايام من الجدل والتصريحات المتضاربه لاحقت
الفنانه اللبنانيه كارول سماحه بعد طرحها
لاغنياتها ستنتهي الحرب والاتهامات التي
لاحقتها بشان تحريف كلمات الاغنيه الجدل
الكبير حول الاغنيه وتعليق مؤسسه محمود
درويش التي استنكرت استخدام كلمات الاغنيه
المحرفه وعدم مراعاه المنتجين للالبوم
لحقوق الملكيه دفع الفنانه الى الرد اخيرا
كارول سماحه رفض اتهامها بتحريف كلمات
الاغنيه واكيدتنا حصلت على حقوق ملكيه
القصيده من المؤسسه الفلسطينيه قبل اصدار
الالبوم الفنانه اثرت بيانا عبر محاميها
جون قانو اكدت فيه رفضها للتمادي
بالمغالطات وتحريف الواقع مؤكده احترام
ارث الشاعر محمود درويش والرد لضروره الحد
من المغالطات والاتهامات
من اين حصلتم على الاذن في البدء جرى
تواصل
مع المؤسسه قبل انتاج العمل
لنيل الاذن باعتبار المؤسسه ابلغتنا انه
يجب نيل الاذن قبل اصدار اي عمل يعود الى
قصيده او شعر من محمود درويش وبالواقع
بحوالي عشرين اثنين تحديدا بتاريخ 20/2
ارسلنا كتاب الى رئيس المؤسسه ابلغني فيه
انه نحن بصدد نشر 12 قصيده مغنيه من قبل
كارول سميحه من اعمال محمود درويش
وابلغناه ايضا انه ب 23/2 سيتم نشر اول
عمل اللي هو ستنتهي الحرب طلب منا رئيس
المؤسسه ارسال رساله مفصله باسماء القصائد
ارسلنا له اسماء 12 قصيده بما فيهم
ستنتهي الحرب
ب 21/2
استحصلنا على اذن بطرح الالبوم
هل في اوراق رسم
يه موقعه او اتفاقيه بند اتفاق بين
الطرفين وينه لحتى تثبته للعالم انه فعلا
يعني صار في اشي بشكل رسمي مش فقط يعني
ايميلات احيانا يعني ممكن تكون الطرف اول
شيء انا معي
انا معي الاتفاقيه
وثاني شيء شقيقه لمحمود درويش الشاعر احمد
درويش هو اللي نشر الاتفاقيه على صفحه
الفيسبوك من يومين
بس استاذ جون يعني صار في كتير لغط بهذه
المساله واليوم بس كمان انه احنا عم نحكي
عن مؤسسه محمود درويش هي مؤسسه رسميه وهيا
الجهه الاولى والاخيره
بالقرار عن فكره نشر دواوين لمحمود درويش
من عدمه يعني هي كل حقوق النشر والحفظ
محفوظه لهم لو كان فعلا تم تواصل لما كان
حصل البلاغات بسنه تنتهي الحرب بدي صحيح
ما ذكرتيها بالوقت الحاضر اول شيء المرسوم
الذي اعطي لمؤسسه محمود درويش هي احياء
تراث محمود درويش اما حقوق المؤلف لمحمود
درويش هي تنتقل بالارث هذا حق شخصي لا
يمكن لاحد مصادرته اذا حقوق المؤلف تنتقل
حصرا الى الورثه والورثه هن اللي بيعطوا
حق بنشر اعمال محمود درويش سواء عن طريق
الغناء او عن طريق التلحين مش المؤسسه
المؤسسه
بلغتنا انه استحصلت على ترخيص من الورثه
اذا المؤسسه ببنيان القانونه ليس لها حق
باعطاء حق استغلال كلمات محمود درويش
بينما هذا الحق يعود حصرا الى الورث ونحن
عندما ادركنا انه مؤسسه محمود درويش لا
تملك هذا الحق لجانا الى الورثه واستحصلنا
على ترخيص منهم باستغلال جميع كلمات
الالبوم ستنتهي الحرب بمجرد ما تلقينا خبر
من مؤسسه انه ستنتهي الحرب هي منسوبه الى
محمود درويش وليست من اعماله المؤكد
المؤكده دغري بشرنا اتصالاتنا مع اليوتيوب
والمنصات من اجل تعديل الكليب وحذف اسم
محمود درويش
[موسيقى]